look who's entering the studio now hey
man McNulty's here hi dawn welcome real
good yes welcome to the show it's awful
really yeah is it are you not a you know
an early guy you really need to ask Nick
Nolte everybody [ __ ] this morning and
told them I got fish for breakfast
what kind of fish did you have fish oh
yeah
I just want to feel bad all I want to
ask you about is one of my favorite
movies is a QA mmm how much fun was that
to do he said just to ask you about it
you got insecure for the second time sky
while I'm showering I realize I have no
good thing to throw me under the bus he
knows yeah well he knows my stick you
know I told him all sir sighs I sit near
him and I was doing an Arthur Miller
piece called everybody wins
which lot of people don't know it comes
from a little one-act play called some
kind of love story which is really about
Marilyn but you know I to convince
anybody that said that the weight didn't
work um it was with Deborah Wang and
Carol rice winger was tough um a good
way or a bad way bad way Oh tough
schwarber that's why I worked with her
here much sex ed I just think craziness
so Sidney had cast me already because
the costume lady had the scrip so I read
it and it was about this big pretty
darling of New York cop that was rogue
didn't all that stuff and Sidney said
when you're on your way through West
Virginia stop in where every through so
I said okay Sidney but I haven't started
work on yet I was like a svelte 165 and
look like that kid over there yeah dark
yeah now walking on these actors and
Sidney look at me is it oh no no this
won't do and I
Sydney I haven't started yet I promise
ya go down to West Virginia I'll come
back to New York once a month and when
I'm doing go down put on 20 pounds and
I'd lift my shoes an inch so when I
finally reached about six foot six and
was two fifty sixty pounds I look down
listen yes it is this big enough
stop stop sit down get a great mustache
in that that was so good you can [ __ ]
transwomen I was such an awesome movie
lock that Q&A is the best dialogue of
its most underrated movie I've ever done
Marlon Brando's favorite film
he liked every performance he wanted to
know about the transfers vests tights
international crisis
where was the penis did you really reach
down in there offer Sylvester the
prostitute I'm Sophia I grab that
chicken balls awesome thing I like to do
he liked them unless Ronny what he did
boy all those guys were Randall like
that movie that's awesome he wouldn't
you're on vacation without that movie I
wish I would want to show him that
Marlon Brando we could have just swapped
Q&A quotes we'd had something in common
it's such a good for you in his
neighborhood
you know he wanted you know here with
Marlon he said how did you do to me well
how did you do Street I you know right
what do you say yeah I got an answer to
that
and what was it what was he amazing
about in the film when was he a
performance he you know it's it's racial
yeah yeah racial and but within the
environment of the station and he liked
he liked that whole thing in the fear of
the guy I was playing with a little
Harry broke that I got from a retired
detective that the judge turned me on to
this a judge
earliest writing I was some under around
New York stuff um he just told me
there's things I can't tell you yeah
Disher answer well the great thing is
there was so much racial language and
homophobic language but it was done in
front of people like it wasn't done they
say this is how a New York cop in this
time a big unfair las' detective would
talk it was really felt very honest yeah
it was it was really raw very very raw
and all the actors wanted to play that
you know if you were playing a
transvestite and these were heterosexual
guys they they'd get all stocking up and
tightened up and hair pulled back and
wrap their penis just lean yeah they got
it's called a gaff you have a time back
yeah
throat over his shoulder yeah we should
text I mean uh yeah Jake knows all his
life
well does I want his passion there was
wine one girl I forget the name it was
Roger Montalvo's uh girlfriend and uh
you want a pot not till you know spoiler
alert but you end up killing her and I
forget her name she was international
crisis yet there that was her name in it
and I said to Sydney I said no it did
you I call she are he boy ah she she's
in a dress first day dumb on the said
she said you a little miniskirt and the
grips are dropping tools to look up her
dress guys are hitting them on the head
and she ain't never won one morning she
said Nick will you talk to Cindy there's
an outfit I want you guys to see that I
I think I can we're in the scene and I
said well I'll go talk to sin yet do we
have to do that he yes so we went to her
dressing room and she said come in when
I said come in she was in a 1/4 inch
fishnet nude stocking from top to bottom
and she had everything replaced of
course
she looked beautiful just beautiful men
down village she said I want you to meet
my mother okay okay I didn't know what I
was gonna meet you don't know sure hello
so I met this tall woman in high heels
very masculine but very beautiful let'em
runs in the family I guess yeah one of
ours a family she died two months after
the film from AIDS always Wow yeah yeah
we have a couple that weeds with lost
matter - aids in the early days and yet
I remember the notorious Ray shark you
know oh yeah yeah yeah the idolmaker
he's both he sold me a bag of weed once
then I spoke old pagan yet I
I guess he picked it matter Wow sound
like your eulogizing him yeah what's
your uh what's your relationship like
now with Martin Scorsese I don't know
I'm not you drop because because I know
there was stuff about you guys in the
past but Cape Fear is like one of my
favorite movies so good you know I had
Marty you know it's got he's in New York
site and so you gotta get in his way in
order to get considered so he wasn't
gonna cast me as a painter so I think it
was Jeffrey Katzenberg that put me in
that and he said well it's only a
15-minute film oh I'll go that way
uh and I had a ball doing life lessons I
mean just a ball oh he did I just stayed
up with trucks on my all night paint it
and then when they come in morning to
shoot Hollywood get pissed off because
he's a painter
what's his stop what's his action [ __ ]
this isn't afraid if again I'll be done
in a bar you know so uh but Cape Fear
they were thinking of Dennis Quaid and I
wasn't on the list
and I was in New York shooting with
Streisand on Prince of tides now Marty
only knew me as a big fat pain that's
really all the way he knew me yeah
so I said to Billy Cross I said let's
put our black suits on go to this casino
party they're gonna have after the
showing and let's just stand against the
wall like we're two lawyers outside that
they watching and see what happens
pretty soon Marty walked by he looked
then he double looked and he came back
over to me say he's a net-net Nick
I said yes Marty Nick he said well wait
a minute I want him Bob would wait right
here please so I waited there then
walked over the shyest man in the world
um who is just naturally that way and
mountain Oh
and Marty said well where are you gonna
be tomorrow 12:00 I said well I'm saying
right around corner the-- the hotel
there we're right around the corner from
your office he said could you be at my
office at 12:00 and I said sure sure
I'll be there so I just put some glasses
on and I went over there Bob was there
and after about two minutes and you know
I don't really need these glasses above
sorry and that's how I got the wrong
that's amazing yeah you're not seen as
like an attorney not not that you don't
look like you could be an attorney but
again you're more of a bruiser yeah 48
hours you would play these aggressive
guys you know we know people just don't
look at you and think litigation what
was a what was it like because this is
one of my other bizarre favorite movies
that I just watch every time it's on
what was it like working with a young
Shaquille O'Neal in blueshifts watch
blue-chip what's that that cardigan that
you give that is talking
uh wait by the way wasn't there a good
food that was the first plug I ever saw
for an airline you're on a plane and you
said something about the best food ever
on a plane you were talking about the
breakfast on a plane is that blue chips
and I'm like that's a [ __ ] product
placement the first time I ever saw that
you know shackle him to my trailer and
all you'd see was and from his dink to
about midway up his chest
uh-huh and he'd shake the trailer said
you know Lee in here
she called me Manali that's it
gasps check what you are I said I wanna
know if she won't come out and play
basketball with us nice and what don't
get have Hardaway you know he ended up
convincing Orlando to uh drop any heart
any wow yeah penny penny told me before
in the Chicago tryouts I was with uh a
Bay High man the Las Vegas guy 13 and
then we were watching from a balcony up
above the penny said you know I'm not
really good to the second quarter or the
second half and they all said better be
good before that because when I guess a
saw a penny shot lights out that day and
that's how you know I never won a game
we played those games
fall out we had 17 cameras on every game
only the last play was read and oh wow
yeah I had peatonal with my assistant
coach which is kind of a godfather
basketball and I couldn't be any 'm I
couldn't beat Bobby Knight I couldn't be
BAE I'm not behind my Pitino or am i
lost all all the games and then when it
came tonight he wouldn't let us to the
trick to win the game he's not
competitive sir this is not March
Madness
no this is about me you saying it's
above me and he just pushed me to get
out of here I'm not losing I'm not
letting that be guy beat me you know and
he had picked his own team you know he
was like he was like different he's like
difficult no he's a great eye I hung
around with him for a month
and I had a friend videotape it it's one
of funniest creative coaching jobs that
he came out one day and he said waders
and he's got a fly rod because I can
anyone like this you see that boys what
am i doing
this is all there's a bit what am i
doing and it went on down catching fish
saw some big I said catching fish he
said no you stupid idiot I'm seeing the
whole court like I took it literally
yeah you know it was a demonstration to
see the whole street now are you a
college sports
I don't watch college sports at all do
you like I do you watch it you gamble on
it or do you not mess obsessed with it
oh you do yeah because see I figured
this if you wanna play football play it
don't go through all that ray Barone on
to school when you know Fiat just send
your high school transcripts and be far
enough away so I play club for years of
junior college ball you know I had to
skip a couple of buses because it would
have caught me I was gonna continue on
better yet but you know now I have pull
back at me in the ironworkers Union we
put the last storm drain and that's a
masculine [ __ ] I know he's got nine
badass live yeah [ __ ] football player
to ironworker Jesus Christ yeah you got
a spin Oh in la-la would be a swampland
and like oh what a [ __ ] anymore
and all those rivers but everything runs
underground and it's our only drainage
water from the hills so I've walked from
Holland all the way to the financial
district and who saved you have to get
out on the sidewalk manhole tea hang it
up and under the street you know you get
run over yeah well they're about 5,000
pounds to lift those things but the
gutters in Beverly Hills are 8 feet long
4 feet wide 3 feet tall you could put
your sleeping bag and live in there you
know Siro Nick plays a former president
in the United States is pretty cool yeah
this guy is great fun to work with you
know I thought at first we were doing a
buddy film yeah yeah started out like my
48 hours dream today every night there's
actually a great scene in it Nick I
wanted to talk to you about that like
the scene when you're when you're
googling yourself when the president the
ex-president is finding out that he's
being ranked as one of the worst
presidents of all time and like you know
do you ever have you ever had that
crisis of conscience yourself have you
ever googled yourself and seen because I
feel like everything every Nick Nolte
story is like you won't believe what he
looks like now and Nick Nolte's wearing
this shirt and these pants and somebody
told me I was a very rich person hmm and
I got maybe a dollar in my pocket you
know so they said googly yourself right
now so I googled it
what is he worth seventy four million
dollars congratulations boy Nicholas
yeah that makes you feel rich you know
but okay it's kind of like Trump it was
all tax write-off oh no I never got the
money you know right I gave it away you
know you know if you don't if you don't
grow up with money you really don't know
how to keep it you know they say that
now I do find it hard to be responsible
with money have you been have you made
some errors well you know first of all
they overwhelm me with the amount
you know I got criticized for turning
Donna me in dollars on several things
Fort Apache and rich man poor man - I
wouldn't do it I said it sure sure sure
when Shah got a right rich man pointment
- oh no no no we'll get some television
writers I said well you know I'm not
going to do it you know unless Arwen
writes a sequel to his book which he did
do called beggar man thief and there was
a series that called beggar man thief so
there is actually rich man poor man -
mega man thief and I'm Owen and show off
of it just over the controversy of doing
- because they called me in first to
tell me that it wasn't gonna be 3 - our
movies they will I gotta didn't a
half-hour shows and call it a miniseries
and then I wasn't old enough to really
give him a lot of [ __ ] but uh I said you
know that's not on my agenda but that's
your agenda ok well if they're making a
miniseries don't they have to just keep
putting little climaxes in there and
then I would think so yeah I didn't see
how they could cut it up but they said
we hadn't in anywhere we cut sup
wonderful
I said well you just trying to stretch
the product out as far as you can and I
went back to work yeah then they called
me in and they said look the offers of
me in dollars we want you to play your
son you know to come back it was very
important to I said to Frank prices are
praying I die at the end
Who am I gonna play he said well you
could come back as your son I don't
think so Frank
yeah and those prophetic words were
spoken he said listen I'll tell you
something and tell you finish your
obligation television you'll not work
film in this town Wow I'll just have to
take my chances more life rain I walked
out did you work from in that town uh
yeah
and then town had called me from
Universal who that film
I said Jaden and yer I'm sorry I can't
take this call
he said wanna offer you a three-picture
deal I said well yeah but I can't work
for you is why well Frank told me and
darling finish me he don't believe that
[ __ ] said no so Fort Apache just a
Paul Newman film that when Danny Aiello
is in that and we what role was it was
Aiello's role or Paul Newman's in the
role it was a 300 page script then
imperative down Wow
you know and I didn't know that much
about New York really and Paul was right
one to do it but I just didn't just
didn't make sense and the guy that was a
producer he had a column and he was just
outraged that I turned on me in dollars
you know but I was never in it for the
money I mean I did almost years 30 years
of theater eating little cans and
spaghetti is little chance of my years
were you acting before you finally got
something like a good payday like how
long would Oh
he's headed about 14 15 years of solid
theatre repertory and summer stock and
then finally it was a William Inge play
Inge took it to LA and I have a at the
time tried to cast it out from under him
and he fired his agency I have a which
is ICM and they'll put the play on in
the content like and tempo furniture
stores there sweetie furniture store
across from UCLA that became Kevin's
Westwood Playhouse but we ran there for
a year yeah it was a rugged play for LA
nobody knew who we were and I had a
trick that I used to as a kid when I
didn't want to go to school I swallowed
a little bit of vegetable soup then hold
it in the upper stomach
and then I'd puke it out so I'd do that
to play and it seemed to get everybody's
attention I don't know a great trick
yeah how you holding your upper stomach
ye just swallowed partway he's kind of
gay and on you all the time
oh okay let's yeah yeah I've had other
things to give that effect to me see let
me ask
I read something that interested me and
it's current more the the the folklore
of Nick Nolte the de mugshot of you that
kind of has sure your hair is all wild
and everything that that was not
actually a mugshot
no no no isn't that crazy I didn't know
that yeah no in fact that was released
in England before was released in the
United States because that was the
anniversary in 9/11 so all the towns
were pointed to New York and to where
the terrorists were going to bomb again
and the only thing they happen on there
that days I got pulled over for driving
under the influence and the guy was very
poetic he said he drove me down the
hospital I wouldn't let them you know I
did the breath thing there was nothing
but I wouldn't had it at the
entertainment hospital do blood test
I didn't think they had the test you
know it was that Noah but they and he
said gee I'm really sorry mr. novian you
know boy hey man I was on the wrong side
of the street Street on PCH sound asleep
running people off the road I'm glad you
stopped me sure I was totally
irresponsible and I saw the camera down
there and we got out of the car he said
they didn't mind if I hit a shot against
the wall and if you look at the wall you
can see that it's two-toned yes I said
yeah yeah yeah' yes' - tom that's not a
mud background so he just asked to take
a photo of you a photo and I said to
look if you'll share the money then I'll
do it he
said share what money either come on
yeah you know don't don't take the first
bit you know they'll probably start
around twenty twenty-five thousand you
can get it up to forty fifty thousand
dollars but share with the other
sheriffs and I don't know if he did it
or not they don't Wow they don't talk
about it they don't like me talking but
but that's the story that's the story my
career issue though is that is the the
shirt choice that's one of the best
things in the world is Nick Nolte's
fashion choices when he's just on his
own left his own accord like the new one
that's everywhere is you walking around
in a poncho you know and it's like it's
like it looks like the most comfortable
guy in the world
yeah but certainly not fashion choices
where he's like oh I'm really worried
what people are gonna think of me today
that's the beauty of me that's what's
gonna say on your on your gravestone
Nick Nolte he didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
bloody left the house it's awesome
native Katharine Hepburn
she doesn't like know she dressed for
comfort that's the first thing she
noticed about me she said I'll be in
dress for comfort yeah I got the same
jeans you have on and then she would
test you you'd go into her apartment New
York she said pick a chair now as a big
cushy chair here there's two big cushy
chairs over here little couch he's gotta
go where would Spence Cole he went it
all over that because she cared be
separated from shooting his wisdom from
the outside and she said mom
congratulations you big Spencer's chair
and then when the producers were in
there she proceeded to just tear them
apart
they'd ask her things like how are you
gonna play this scene inches what I
don't know what I'm gonna play a scene
before I do a scene uh-huh do you know
how you gonna do something before you do
it yeah no it's amazing to ask Katharine
Hepburn that question yeah the boss
asked Katharine Hepburn yeah these guys
can and group they were from what was
the project it was called the ultimate
solution of grace Quigley
and she threw it over the wall and then
called me about three days later and
said did you get it you gave one who is
this it's a Katharine Hepburn I threw
script over your wall don't you jack
Wow God find it now for one and she said
a lash me he's going to produce it
that's okay
I wanted me reading how get all I'll
call you open so I read it was great I
called her I said yeah when can we meet
me in the house she gave me a time so we
got down ashbey's and Hal said you know
I'm not gonna direct this piece because
I've done pieces like this and remember
Donald Pleasence in yeah as a gardener
and be on my breath well it was in that
vein of thing it was about our [ __ ] back
from Vietnam that was a hit man she saw
him take do the hit and now she's older
and she wants to be often and then all
our old friends find out she's leaving
and they want to know what who the angel
is that's often them and then she is
arrogant wants me off the cabdriver so I
decided you know ma I should have shot
you a lot well you said Donald Pleasence
plaintiff I do you mean Peter Sellers
when he did being there or did Donald
Pleasence just yeah right
Peter saw okay hey watch wasn't your
call yeah no no good call Gardner
president yeah the last thing I do is
find out Nick Nolte's test him and he
walks out that's an out of his head yes
when did you officially like feel like
in your soul that you really didn't give
a [ __ ] what people said anymore like is
that something early on ER is that like
once you're kind of established you're
like he gives a [ __ ]
it comes from theater it comes from
theater and you know like going up stock
and doing Luther you know which goes
from one is a young man to middle-aged
to old age and I could never get the
mental age or the old age right but I
could get the young man
right you know and these pulpit speeches
but once you do that play into it solid
really well I did it about four times at
different stages and then you know
you're a thousand seed audience there's
not much that can penetrate you then you
know in films more intermittent if
there's a guy right here that's a
producer Boyd I don't like that I don't
like that you just kick him off set yeah
yeah and I stopped trying to have you
getting it to a certain point before you
can boot the producers oh yeah yeah well
Pacino used to line him up all on the
line everybody behind the camera had to
be shoulder to shoulder so you had fifty
guys lined up on the line Wow that may
be an exaggeration honor what was that
for so that they thought that you
wouldn't have to look at them daily wins
in home with a camera but that's a
different kind of concentration you know
there's a kind that focused down and
then there's the kind that includes
everything I am kind of in inclined to
go with everything that is included
because now you're able to respond if
something dropped you pick it up you
know yet you can go many ways with that
the lockdown
yeah gives you stillness gives you think
nothing but it
I think the concentration is is wide
deer the Christian Bale audio where he's
screaming yeah this is audio Christian
Bale screaming because I guess a light
guy or somebody had walked in his
eyeline behind the camera and he was not
after he should have used that on camera
yeah yeah that's what he should have
saves that just could use the energy
yeah look you know a moment yeah yeah
well what look Nick Nolte I feel like in
the scheme of things you've kind of done
everything right you've got a career
that's longer than most and would be
envied by most and you've gotten to have
every great experience to come from a
bad habit you know I mean like but
usually people have to make the
trade-off either the experiences that
come with those bad habits or the career
and you figure it out
how to do both by the way that poncho
outfit I'm just seeing it for the first
time now I'm a fan yeah I'm a fan of the
poncho outfit right it's very brandish
it
it's very island of dr. Moreau ish but
I'm actually a fan of it yeah you can
you can see the show graves it premieres
on epochs October 16th at 10:00 p.m.
it's a great show Nick Nolte plays an
ex-president
that is kind of coping with life after
being president and far removed from
being president and has this kind of
crisis where he realizes that he was
wrong he thinks he's got about you know
few years left to live and has decided
to completely change his ways and loses
his mind a little bit it's great it's
fun it's good it's uh it's really good
man yeah hope is an alternative to the
elections coming up yeah you know maybe
some people say I mad enough that should
turn into this I don't hope that that's
been told to me you know yeah but I
don't want to get into that yeah yeah I
understand